you've become a very good stand-up by
the way thanks bro and i i want to say
that rarely do i see
somebody that
you know comes you know it you know i'm
a i'm a
organic stand up i i started it started
with it at when i was 23
open mics i did the whole thing and so
it's like when i see like an actor
or you know an entertainer entertainer
like yourself
decide to do stand-up later in their
career whatever
i have to be honest there is like a gut
like reaction of like come on you know i
mean what the [ __ ] you know i mean
but so it takes a while for me to go
to watch somebody and go
you know what
theo did it because theo was theo von
was you know
house rules yeah he was on some mtv show
right and then he started doing stand up
and we were kind of like why is this guy
and then he became you're
very much like that where it's like a
guy that
you know you're from jackass and it's
like you did it and you put in the work
that's the thing
it's like
it's hard you know how hard it is stand
up
and when you're one of those guys that
like
is you're an actor and you do it once in
a while
right to make a quick buck or whatever
right it just doesn't um sit well with
me but when somebody
goes you know i know that this is a
completely different craft
and i'm gonna put in the [ __ ] work
then i can gain a respect
because i'm sure you had some
suffering when you start doing stand-up
you know sure how hard it was yeah yeah
and
i also
um
was fortunate that i didn't realize how
bad it was
like i was eating [ __ ] but i didn't
really know that
yeah yeah yeah i just took the laughs
that i got and the last that i got
really put wind in my sails
and kept me at it um and uh
and and i also had when i when i started
doing it um i i was
uh i mixed in stunts like every like
even if i did two shows friday two shows
saturday i'm still doing all those
stunts over and over and over and over
again wow wow and uh and that kind of
helped me along but dude thank you so
much man i really do
because i remember even before you did
it though i would see you at the clubs
in the audience yeah right so it's like
you know i mean you're doing you're
studying as well like how does this work
and i mean
that was when i got sober and i'm not
going to bars i'm not going to
nightclubs anymore they're the only
place that i would go would be to the
comedy club because i had a reason to be
there yeah but that in that way also
it's like okay he's trying to like learn
the thing yeah
but it's cool i think rapaport does it
you know i mean i you know i
good things about his stand up i like
piven as well you know i mean he's
putting the work in though you know me
he goes up a lot yeah and when people go
up like i just don't like it when like
you know
i don't want to name names but there
have been people that
did it and they just decided just to go
on the road
like they did went up twice
and all of a sudden because they have a
name they went on the road and then
with that hat what happens is then they
sell out
a big club
and they eat a dick
and then they stop doing it because it's
so brutal right that's not what you did
you kind of slowly
got there
i got them i got to hitting the road
pretty quickly
you know
i i dove into it i started doing it all
all the time all the time
and uh and then i was presented with the
opportunity to get on the road when our
jackass 3d came out ah so so i got into
it pretty pretty quickly wasn't it from
a howard stern interview yeah i went on
howard to promote jackass 3d and i was
like howard i'm doing stand-up every
night and i love it and i want to do it
in new york tonight
and i did it at the seller that night
yeah how long did you do
like 10 minutes sad at the seller like
whatever was it hard
seller can be a little intimidating i
mean yeah okay it was it's intimidating
it was even when i play the seller it's
like this is you know it's the comedy
store of new york i think it's like
that's deep history
everyone's a killer
you know i but uh
you know but whatever it is man i always
did take it seriously i always did care
about it and i work hard
and then thank you man it's called
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole and
if you go on amazon and type in stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're
ranked number 30 on all of amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on amazon and buy stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude